in a faithful turn for the medical
industry the p IP scandal exploded on
the scene
the French breast implant manufacturer
was accused of inserting a dangerous gel
into the chests of nearly 400,000 women
across the globe yet a post into
estrogen the the silicone and whiskey
Anna said that Nepal is not in a toy for
men properly motivate you don't on
Oakland many estrogen no we don't
Deportes como don't call this a famine
nevertheless the p IP company the third
ranking producer of prosthetics in the
world had managed to get its product
certified by a well known notified body
lost Mesa city limits on Russia and
dispositive mini characters who are in
psoriasis women portes marry too busy
doctor near co-op composing
certification settle actual Qadri a
confirm a condition the list a very few
a Aakash apologia certificate Oh
a spate of similar medical scandals has
encouraged the European Union to react
to better define the legal framework
governing medical devices the goal of
the medical devices regulation is
primarily and absolutely to make sure
that patients are safe and I think
there's another part of this story which
is really important that we have a
medical devices industry in Europe which
is incredibly innovative so it was with
that in mind that we looked at this
regulation to see could we design a new
piece of legislation that looked after
patients and promoted innovation in the
industry in a very safe way for all of
us the medical device industry is a
major economic player in Europe
employing five hundred and seventy-five
thousand people in the EU and achieving
a hundred billion euros per year in
total sales the goal of the new
regulations is to protect this key
sector and most importantly the health
of the many citizens that it serves
how do we do that we are insisting under
this regulation that notified bodies
need to have the necessary skills and so
that they can do the job that they are
being asked to do and that they also in
addition to how they work now carry out
unannounced inspections so look what
we're talking about here is greater
scrutiny greater scrutiny and greater
scrutiny that's how the European
Parliament wants to improve regulation
in both medical devices and in vitro
diagnostic devices that have an
important place in our daily life in
vitro diagnostic machine product and
other tests Dion - I know kanketsu
attendant methods of 144 or normative
those clients Wester their medicine
doctor for gangrene Ryan Hughes Dimity
and before Ana therapy Jewish fever and
operati own and many comment or and it's
improved and that solution as my vision
was a dementia my dentist and our
February the diagnostic very simple
doctor and Adamson is aware my view of
this regulation is rebuild trust and
greater surveillance a greater checks at
every point in the chain so that all of
us will have access now and in the
future to these incredible devices that
save lives